[synth music]
This was a pop up exhibit
for first-year physics students,
and it's all about
introducing them to rare books
that are related
to their first year
physics classes.
And that means
that these are
the oldest and rarest
books at the Beinecke.
(Chiara)
Oh, these are all of
the calculations!
To be able to share that
with my students
and to see how excited
they all were,
undergraduate students,
graduate students,
it was just such a treat.
I think that
these books are
so important, even in
2023 for a few reasons.
Number one,
a lot of the things that
they wrote
down are still true today.
And that's the amazing thing
about science.
(student #1)
Currently, inventing calculus.
Super cool.
The second thing is
that some of these books
go into great detail
about how difficult
these calculations were.
And those kind of feelings
are the things that we
also feel as researchers
and scientists.
And so giving students
that connection
it's just such an amazing link
to the past
and makes these books
really relevant,
not only from the historical
point of view,
but from a cultural, scientific
point of view.
These are their academic
ancestors.
For me, that's the most
important thing, is saying that
these really famous scientists
that are elevated
were clearly brilliant people,
but they're still just people.
And the books themselves
have such interesting character.
There's other people
that wrote in the margins
and really just the sense
of holding a piece of history
piece of history
in your hand.
It was really incredible.